hey guys today it is Wednesday the 29th
of July and you are watching games
button you open world zombie games dying
light is getting a fairly meaty
expansion called the following the
expansion is free if you already picked
up the twenty-dollar dying light DLC
pass but it will also be available to
purchase separately for a
yet-to-be-determined price among other
things the expansion will introduce June
buggy vehicles that you can use to maim
your zombie foes in a whole new way
techland has also confirmed a new map
which will be the same size as all the
previous time like Maps combined the
developer have said the following will
be feature heavy and have a whole new
story our release date is yet to be
announced well as it has revealed that
the next major world of warcraft
expansion is going to be announced next
week at Gamescom the sixth expansion
will follow on from warlords of Draenor
which came out last year it's not a huge
shock that the announcement is coming
now given that in 2013 Blizzard
confirmed that a follow-up to the drain
or expansion was already in the works
Blizzard has previously stressed that
providing gamers with full paid
expansions in addition to free updates
is crucial to keeping the game relevant
the newest expansion will be announced
on Thursday august six at nine a.m. PDT
there will also be a developer chat on
Sunday morning of that week which will
go into more detail about the expansion
when those ten is out today and if you
already have windows seven or eight you
can even get it for free initial reviews
of the OS have been fairly positive and
the offer to upgrade for free if you're
an existing Windows 7 or 8 user is
available for a year Windows 10 features
a brand new xbox gaming out Microsoft's
voice activated intelligent personal
assistant called Cortana and a new
browser called edge which let's face it
can't be any less popular than internet
explorer most significantly for Xbox
owners it features the ability to stream
xbox one games to your PC
and Phil Spencer is said that Microsoft
is looking into pc to xbox one game
streaming too for the full review and
details on how to upgrade to Windows 10
ahead to our story on gamespot planner
down in the comments if you're excited
for Windows 10 or not and why you can
add the game spot we've got stories on
the way you passing 10 million units
sold and next month PS Plus games that
is everything I wanted to tell you about
today I will be back same time tomorrow
so I'll catch oven